welcome to the I am overview and
policies section in this section we're
going to have a look at I am and provide
an overview of what it is and what it's
used for then we're going to take a look
at I am policies and finally we'll do a
demonstration of how to create an ion
policy in AWS so what is I am well
identity and access management is the
service that enables you to securely
control user access to all your AWS
services and resources it's based around
the concept of user management that
you'll already be familiar with users
groups and permissions so here we're
just going to go through the key
features of I am and then we'll cover
each of them in more depth so the first
thing is it gives you shared access to
your account it provides granular
permissions
it gives secure access to AWS resources
it can provide identity Federation and
if you're not sure what that is we'll
cover that identity information for
assurance which is crucial these days
with all the auditing that goes on its
PCI DSS compliant it allows you to set
up a password policy and also
multi-factor authentication so let's
take a look at each of these in detail
now I am provides shared access to your
account which allows you to grow on
other people in your organization
permission to administer and use AWS
resources in your account without you
having to share your password or access
key now when you set up your AWS account
for the first time you give an email
address and a password and this is
effectively your root account so you
obviously don't want to be sharing this
for people but there's an admin user you
can use I am to share access so for
example is a bunch of users they need
access to ec2 and s3 and you can
permission them to do that and not only
you could have used access in just s3
you could have another group of users
accessing are the SNS three you know and
it's endless what you can do I am
allowing you to set up very granular
permissions so using I am users and
groups you can grant different
permissions
two different people to manage their
access to AWS so you can really define
which users can access which services
for example you could have a bunch of
users that can have access to ec2
production instances but not to
development instances and as you'll see
as we go on you can get very granular
you can start development teams to have
read/write access two volumes but
without administration access or
development teams that can add new
storage volumes to development instances
but are not allowed to launch new
instances I am allows you to securely
allocate the credentials that
applications running on ec2 instances
need so that they can access other AWS
resources for example s3 buckets or
databases and this diagram here which
we'll go over in a later section gives
you a rough idea but what you need to
know at this stage is that if you have
an application that runs on an ec2
instance and the ec2 instance has been
configured accordingly and I am the
application can automatically inherit
the permissions it needs to go and
access s3 buckets or databases without
actually having to store or pass user
credentials
I am allows you to set up identity
Federation so you can allow users who
already have passwords elsewhere for
example Facebook Microsoft Active
Directory or Google to get temporary
access to your AWS account now you
probably use this in applications where
when you set up a new account you have
options to log in using Facebook or your
gmail account and that's basically
identity Federation now a hot topic
these days is identity information or
auditing and I am allows you to log
monitor and track what users are doing
with your AWS resources through the use
of cloud trail now there's a whole
section on cloud trail later in this
course here's a brief overview for you
it logs everything user time we logged
in IP addresses and it will write it to
a log and store it in an s3 bucket where
you can have full administration control
and you can keep all the log files there
for well for as long as you want or
until the auditors come knocking
I am is PCI DSS compliant which means it
is payment card industry and data
security standard compliant in other
words it can process store and print
transmit credit card data from a
merchant or service provider I am has
multi-factor authentication built-in so
you can configure two-factor
authorization for users and resources to
ensure absolute security using MFA
devices all these days it's easier and
simpler to use MFA applications on your
mobile phone such as Google
Authenticator so I'm sure you've all
been in here and done this where you
have to login to a website and then
you're asked to enter your 6-digit pin
and you look at your device and type it
in well that's what multi-factor
authentication is and finally password
policy I am allows you to define
password strength and rotation policies
and also the number of characters and
special characters etc so you can really
lock down your passwords accessing AWS
so what are I am policies well a policy
is a document that defines one or more
permissions and policies can be attached
to users groups and roles they're
written in something called a JavaScript
object notation or JSON for short and
we're going to look at an example of
this in a few slides time and there are
a number of policies that AWS has
predefined which you can select from or
you can create and edit your own so as I
mentioned AWS has many predefined
policies which allow you to define
granular access to AWS resources and
here's a screenshot of the policy page
where you can see there's around 200
policies that are available for use at
the moment so let's take a look at a
couple of them so you can get more of an
idea of what a policy is one of the most
commonly used policies is administrator
access policy and this provides full
access to AWS services and resources so
it's kind of the administrator slash
root user so here's your admin user and
here is a screenshot of the Amazon Web
Services console with all the services
available so if you have the
admin user administrator access policy
you can do whatever you want you can go
in and access absolutely everything so
you would only be giving this to a
select few people another popular policy
is Amazon ec2 full access policy now
this provides full access to Amazon ec2
and the associated resources which are
elastic load balancer cloud watch and
auto scaling so if your users have this
they can do what they want with ec2 but
they have no access to any other
services Amazon s3 read-only access
policy this policy provides read-only
access to all buckets via the AWS
management console so here's your users
you've given them this policy they have
read-only permissions on s3 but they
have no other permissions on any other
services so as you can see you can get
very granular with your policy creation
as I mentioned earlier AWS policies are
written in something called JSON or
JavaScript object notation which stores
data and easily readable key value pairs
now here's an example of an AWS policy
written in JSON and as you can see it's
not that complicated so let's break this
down so at the top there are some policy
wide information that helps you identify
details about the policy in this case
it's diversion but you could put
whatever you want here then there's a
statement section kind of the meat of
the JSON policy and this is where the
policy rules are written in this example
there are three entries there's the
effect which is the effect the user has
when they request access which is either
allow or deny in this case the default
is that resources are denied to users so
you typically specify that you will
allow users access rather than
vice-versa then there's the action and
this is the action that you will allow
so each AWS service has its own set of
actions and in this example we're
allowing s3 list bucket access and any
actions that you don't explicitly allow
are denied so users will be able to list
the contents of the bucket but they
weren't bare to do anything else and
finally there's the resource and this is
the resources that you are allowing the
action to take place on in this example
we're allowing lists bucket access on
the example bucket and users with this
policy won't go to access any other
buckets
welcome to the ion policy creation demo
in this demo I want to create a new
policy that allows read-only access to
an Amazon s3 bucket called simply learn
so to do this I'm going to go to the
security and identity section and click
on Identity and Access Management
you
on the next page I'm going to click on
policies on the left hand side and here
we have a list of all the Amazon
predefined policies as you can see this
quite a few and you can tell that Amazon
predefined because they have this little
Amazon box logo next to them so we want
to create a new policy and represented
with three different options the first
of which is copy and AWS manage policy
so we can start with an AWS policy and
customize it to fit our needs secondly
as the policy generator where we can
select services and actions from a list
and the policy generator will create a
policy for us or you can create your own
policy using the policy editor and
editing JSON code manually now we're
going to select the first option because
this is easy as for what we need to do
so we'll click on select and represent
it with a list of policies now we want
an s3 policy so if we type s3 into the
search we can see there's two options
s3 full access and s3 read-only access
so we want the latter we'll click select
and here's our policy so as you can see
it's given a predetermined policy name
and which is Amazon s3 read-only access
and is put the date in here so we want
to remove that and we want to give it a
more meaningful name so we'll call it
simply learn s3 read-only access as a
description saying what it is so we want
to provide read-only access to simply
learn buckets via the AWS management
console then we get to the policy
document which is written in JSON so as
you can see we have the version which we
won't need to change and then we have
the statement and the effect is allow so
we're allowing the action and the action
is s3 get an s3 list and there's the
resource at a minute it says Asterix
which means all s3 buckets so in
to change this so I'll cut and paste in
this code that I copied from the Amazon
website which is basically saying AWS s3
and then the name of the bucket we're
giving access to so we'll change this to
simply learn and we're giving read
access to all files in the simple urn
bucket now on the bottom there's a
button called validate policy so we can
see whether my code is correct so we
click on that and it says this policy is
valid so yes the code is fine so now
we're okay to click create policy and
there at the top it says simply learn s3
read-only access has been created now
you are ready to attach your policy to
users groups and roles so let's look for
it in our policy list so we'll type in
s3 and now we are simply there an s3
read-only access and you can tell that
is a user defying policy because there's
no Amazon box next to the name so there
we are now we're ready to use our s3
read-only policy which we will look at
use in following lessons welcome to the
I am users groups and roles section in
this section we're going to take a look
at what I am users groups and roles are
used for and then we'll have a
demonstration on how to create each of
them in the AWS management console so
what are I am uses well users are
defined as the people or systems that
use your AWS resources they can be
administrators you need to access the
AWS console and manage your resources
well it can be end-users like
developers or production support who
need to access AWS content or they can
even be systems that need permissions to
access your AWS data so AWS provides a
number of different ways to provide
secure access to your AWS resources and
we're going to look at them here so the
first one is an email address and
password and this is created when you
first sign up to use AWS and it allows
you access to the AWS management console
discuss
forums and support center now this
shouldn't be shared of anyone else as
it's effectively the route account for
your AWS resources the next option which
we're discussing in this lecture is the
I am username and password and this
allows multiple individuals or
applications access to your AWS account
each user can use his or her own
usernames and passwords to sign in to
the AWS management console and
discussion forums and support center
next is multi-factor authentication or
MFA for short and AWS MFA enabled when
you sign into an AWS website you're
prompted for your username and password
as well as an authentication code from
your MFA device these multiple factors
provide increased security for your AWS
account settings and resources now
access keys they come as an access key
ID and a secret access key and these are
provided to you whenever you set up a
new I am user you use access keys to
sign programmatic requests that you make
to AWS whether you're using the AWS SDK
rest or query API so what this basically
means is that developers don't need to
store or pass credentials to AWS
resources this is all done behind the
scenes for you by AWS and here is an
example of an access key ID and a secret
access key and we'll look at this
further in the demo that follows this
lesson and finally there are key pairs
now key pairs consist of a private and
public key and are used only for Amazon
ec2 and Amazon Cloud rather you use the
private key to create a digital
signature which AWS validates against
the corresponding public key so that's
just an extra layer of security so
before we go to the demo I'd like to ask
you which of these options would you
choose would you rather have your users
logging straight into Amazon Web
Services all using the same
administration accounts or would you
rather users log in with their own
individual accounts using I am well
obviously is the latter you want to
create individual accounts for each
user that accesses your AWS resources so
you can tighten down exactly what
security they use you can have auditing
capabilities so you know who's doing
what and when and it will simplify the
management of your systems because if
you're all using the same user when you
change the password you have to tell
everyone
but if everyone's using their own
individual user accounts let's see the
steps to create an iamb user so in this
demonstration we're going to create a
new user and create their password so
that someone can log into the AWS
console without having to use a shared
account so to do this we'll start in the
security and identity section and click
on I am and we will move to the left
hand side and click on users and you can
see that currently there's only one user
in here and that's me but we want to
create a new user so let's click on
create new users and you can enter some
usernames to create now we're going to
create a new user called simply learn
user which is going to be our basic
read-only simply learn a camp and
there's an option here to generate an
access key for each user these are not
used in the user name password type
scenario instead they use to allow
access to AWS via external tools such as
command-line interface and we'll
covering that more in the ec2 section
now you only get to see these
credentials once so you need to download
them so we will click on create user now
it tells me that my user has been
created successfully and also that this
is the last time these user security
credentials will be available for
download so if I click on show user
credentials there I can see my simply
learn access key ID and secret access
key ID now you don't need to know these
you just need to save them down into a
safe place so that you can use them to
access other resources so if I click on
download credentials in the bottom right
and it will create a credentials CSV
file now when I click close that's the
last time I'll see those
okay so there's my new user simply learn
user now at the moment if someone was
had this account and they wanted the
login to the console I couldn't because
we haven't set a password so that's the
next thing we're going to do so we click
on user actions and manage password and
we have two options we can either assign
an auto-generated password or we can
assign a custom password if we wanted to
type something in but whichever you
choose it's always a good idea to
require the user to change their
password the next time they log in now
we're going to use an assign an
auto-generated password and we'll click
on apply and it tells me that my
password has been created and again this
is the last time these credentials will
be available so we can show them and
there's the password and we can also
click download to push them into another
CSV file for safekeeping so we'll click
on close and now we can see that my user
has been created and there's a tick
against the password and we can also see
that it's never being used because
obviously I've just set this up so what
else can we do well let's click on the
user now we're under the security
credentials tab now if the user forgot
their password at any point in time we
could click on manage passwords and with
its various options of how we can reset
their password for them also we can see
here here are the access keys for that
user and if we manage to lose the keys
or we wanted to replace them we can
click create access key here and we'll
generate some new ones but we're not
going to do that now the last thing I'd
like to show you here is the
multi-factor authentication device and
it's currently set to no now for
administration accounts it's always a
good idea to setup MFA access and we
could do that by clicking manage MFA
device and then you would choose a
virtual MFA device or a hardware MFA
device now these days most people would
you have a software device on their
mobile phone if you're as old as I am
then you probably used to use like a
hardware token that you had to carry
around of you on your keychain so we'll
select a virtual MFA device
and then it says to activate a virtual
MFA device you must first install an AWS
MFA compatible application on your
smartphone PC or other device now I have
Google authenticate on my phone and then
what it does is it gives you a QR code
and you use your mobile phone the Google
Authenticator application to scan the QR
code so you can it will generate some
numbers so I'm just going to do that now
and I've just scanned that on my mobile
phone so now it's going to give me some
numbers to type in so if I type in and
is the new one and I click on activate
virtual MFA and there we are my MFA
device was successfully associated with
this device so now every time I want to
log in as the simply learn user
I'll also be requested to type in my
security code from Google Authenticator
and that concludes the I am user
creation demonstration
now an IM group is defined by Amazon as
a collection of users that all inherit
the same set of permissions so that's
pretty standard user security
terminology so let's take a look at the
scenario imagine you are the security
administrator for your company so
whenever a new user joins your company
you need to give them the permissions
they require so they can do their job
properly if you're granting permission
to the users that means every time a new
developer joins you have to log in and
give their user the development
permissions then vennett an
administrator joins you have to give
them the administrator permissions and
so on now obviously this is a time
consuming and inefficient way of doing
thing and that's where groups come in by
granting permissions at the group level
means you only have to set the
permissions once so you as the admin
user can create a group called
developers and give it the appropriate
permissions and you can create a group
called admins and give it the
administrator permissions then when new
people join it's just a case of adding
their user into the appropriate group
let's see the steps to create an iamb
group so in this demonstration we're
going to create an iamb group so that we
don't have to grant permissions to users
individually so let's start again
security and identity Identity and
Access Management section and we will
move to the left-hand side and this time
we're going to click on groups ok so at
the minute we can see there's one group
in my account and that's administrators
so I click on that we can see that it
just has me in there
so what we want to do is create a
read-only group for our simply learn
user so we go to create new group we
give the group a name which we're going
to call simply learn underscore
read-only so this is a restricted user
group that only has read-only access
click on next step on the bottom right
and now we get to attach
policy to our group now if you remember
a few lectures back we created the
simply learn read-only access policy and
we're going to attach that policy to our
simply learn read-only group so we tick
on the box and we click next step and
then we get to review so it's we get to
review the name of chosen and the policy
we've applied so we're happy with that
so we'll click on create group and there
we are now we can see there is our new
simply learn underscore read-only group
now at the minute it has no users
attached to it so if we tick the box
next to simply then read-only go to
group actions and we want to add users
to the group so as to use available me
or simply then user so let's click on
simply learn user and click add users
and there we are now we can see that
there's one user in the group if we
click on this we can see that the simply
learned user is in this group we look at
the permissions and we can see that
there's one policy attached to this
group and it's to simply learn s3
read-only access policy so now whenever
a new person starts in the organization
and they require this permission we just
simply add them to the group and that
concludes the I am group creation
demonstration so what are I am roles
well anion role is similar to a user
it's basically an AWS identity with
permission policies that determine what
the identity can and cannot do however
the difference between a role and a user
is that there is no password or access
key associated with it and it can be
assumed by anyone who needs to use it so
how do roles work well roles can be used
to delegate access to users applications
or services that are not typically able
to access your AWS resources so if you
look at the diagram here this is an
example of a mobile app that wants
permission to use AWS but doesn't
actually store AWS keys in the app
itself so we cover this in more detail
in ec2 section but the brief overview
here is that step one is that the
administrator creates a role that gives
read access to the photos Barket then
you launch an instance with this role so
that means that any application or user
that accesses or users or runs on this
instance will automatically inherit the
permissions of the role so when the
application runs it retrieves the role
conduct credentials from the instance
which means it can access the photos
bucket and then the application performs
the action it requires which is getting
photos from the bucket let's see the
steps to create an iamb role okay in
this final demo for I am we are going to
create a role so as we've seen we've
created users and policies and groups
that allow people to have access to our
s3 simply learn bucket now say we had an
application that needed to run on an ec2
instance and also needed read-only
access to this bucket well we can create
a role and allocate that to the ec2
instance so that it has permissions
automatically so to do that we'll go to
security and identity and the I am
option back over to the left-hand side
where I'm sure you're now getting very
familiar with and we'll click on roles
as you can see there's a few roles in
here already for various things but we
want to create a new role so we're going
to call this simply learn s3 read-only
and that's going to be our role so we
click on next step as you can see
there's various options here
there's the AWS service role which
allows resources to call AWS services on
your behalf you have the role for cross
account access so you can provide access
between AWS accounts you own or AWS
accounts from other companies or
organizations and it's also a role for
identity provider access so here you can
set up your federated access or your
single
sign-on using sam'l now in this example
we want to keep it simple we want to
create an Amazon ec2 instance that has
read-only access to our s3 bucket so we
click on select and here's the policy
page now we want to select our simply
learn s3 read-only access so we select
the policy we click on next step we get
to review so we have the roll name we
have the trusted entity which is ec2 and
we have our policy which is the simply
learn s3 read-only access so we click on
create role and there is the new role
created so if we click on that we can
just have a look and we can verify that
it has the s3 read-only policy and
trusted identities are Amazon ec2 now
when we get to the ec2 section of this
course we can launch an ec2 instance
with this role and it would
automatically inherit the details and
the rules of this particular policy
so this is iron best practices and this
is the final lesson in the iron section
and we'll give an overview of the AWS
recommended best practices for using I
am firstly you should always create
individual I am users this means that
everyone in your organization will have
unique credentials and you can control
their permissions at an individual level
it's also much easier to make users
rotate their credentials when you're not
using shared accounts we all know how
complicated and difficult it can be to
try and change passwords on shared
accounts ie impossible and if you're
using individual users it's much easier
to identify security breaches because
then you can do a forensic investigation
and you can pinpoint exactly where the
problem came from with shared accounts
that's probably not going to happen when
you create iron policies make sure that
you grant least privilege in other words
only grant the permissions that your
users require to perform only the task
they have to do although it's much
easier to grant elevated credentials
from the start is not good practice and
it's much more secure to start with
minimum permissions required and grant
additional access as required trust me
when I say it's easier to grant
permissions to a user than trying to
revoke them the goal of I am is really
to protect your assets first rather than
to make your life easier so you really
should grant only what users actually
need you should always manage
permissions with groups for the main
reason it will minimize your workload
drastically as it's easier to assign a
permission to a group and to assign it
to many individual users as one change
to a group will update the permissions
for multiple users it's also simpler to
reassign permissions if ur usage has a
changing responsibilities for example if
a developer moves to the admin team you
just have to move the user account from
the developer group to the admin group
and your work is complete the
alternative would be to have to
completely reassign the permissions for
each individual user and using groups
means it's also easier to keep track of
your security configuration if an
auditor comes to you and says let me
know all the people that have
administration access to a particular
ec2 instance if you're in groups you
just say hey here's the list of users if
you're not using groups that means you
have to go through each individual user
to find out what they're doing where
possible is always a good idea to add
additional access control to ensure that
your resources are fully protected
examples of this are adding further
conditions like the use of MFA to login
or specifying the access to certain
resources can only come from a
particular IP address a good example of
this would be allowing RDP access to a
production server you could insist that
to log in with an account that has this
permission the user first needs to
connect using MFA and then once logged
in you can specify that they can only
RDP from a server with a particular
range of IP addresses this means that
anyone that fails this security check
won't be able to RDP in there are
several features available in AWS that
you can use the log user actions the log
file show the time and date of actions
the source IP for an action and which
actions fail due to inadequate
permissions and many many more the best
monitoring tool for I am is cloud trail
which we talked about briefly earlier
which logs AWS API calls and related
events made on or behalf of an AWS
account and here's that diagram again
and you can see that user activity is
written to a log and stored in an s3
bucket for use in the future it's an
obvious one but obviously very important
you need to ensure that your users
require strong passwords and that they
rotate their passwords periodically as
you can see in a screenshot here this is
the ion password policy page and using
it you can define a suitable password
policy to set requirements such as
minimum length whether it requires non
alphanumeric characters and how
frequently there must be rotated and
many more applications that run on
Amazon ec2 instances need credentials so
they can interact with other AWS
products and services now we've seen
this diagram before but rather than
making your developers pass credentials
to Amazon EC
- you can use I am roles so that
temporary credentials are dynamically
passed ec2 this means that there's no
need to share crude security credentials
and no need to store long term
credentials I am will also automatically
rotate these credentials for you
so as in this diagram suggest when you
launch new ec2 instances you can specify
an iamb role for the instance then any
applications that run on this particular
ec2 instance will automatically inherit
the roles credentials when they access
AWS you should also reduce or remove
unnecessary credentials you shouldn't
use the root account unless absolutely
necessary and instead you should create
accounts that only have the access
required also you can run a credential
report to remove I am credentials that
aren't needed so if you run a report and
you can see that particular passwords
and access Keys have not been used in a
long time you can remove them to tighten
up your security this is the practice
assignment for configuring I am access
where you'll use I am to configure user
access to AWS as the admin for your
company's AWS account you need to assign
permissions to for new users to users
require full access to ec2 one user
requires administration access to all
AWS resources and one user requires
read-only access to s3 use AWS best
practices when configuring the user
access so be sure to make use of groups
you can now log in to your AWS console
and practice the given scenario which
should ideally take you around ten to
fifteen minutes to complete
welcome to the key takeaway section
AWS identity and access management
allows you to securely control access to
your AWS services and resources for your
users policies which are written in JSON
allow you to define granular access to
AWS resources users are defined as the
people or systems that usually AWS
resources like administrators or
end-users or systems that need
permissions that access your AWS data
groups are a collection of users that
all inherit the same set of permissions
and can be used to reduce your user
management overhead
I am roles are similar to users but they
can be assumed by anyone who needs them
and a role does not have a password or
access key associated with it roles are
used to delegate access to users
applications or services AWS also has a
list of ion best practices to ensure
that your environment is secure and safe
this concludes the identity and access
management lesson the next lesson is
virtual private cloud hey there let us
now talk about the third lesson of the
AWS Solutions Architect course we all
know that security is a critical part of
any IT infrastructure and a key part of
a Solutions Architect
role is to ensure that all resources
residing on the AWS cloud are securely
protected you need to ensure that
resources can only be reached by the end
users or applications that should be
accessing them for this you have to
design and control the security access
to AWS so that end users and
applications do not have more
permissions than they need along with
this you have to enforce strict password
policies to make sure there are no weak
points of entry into your cloud
environment fortunately AWS makes it
easy to do all of this and more how
through the AWS identity access
management service that enables you to
securely control access to AWS services
and resources for your users this lesson
will cover all the features available
within the AWS Identity and Access
Management Service so let's begin
by the end of this lesson you will be
able to describe the key features of I
am and how they can simplify and secure
user access to AWS use the AWS policies
to define permissions to AWS users
explain the steps to create users in AWS
describe how groups simplify I am
management use roles to delegate access
to the AWS resources list the best
practices for I am
you